Hello my name is Jonathan Worth and as
well as being freelance photographer I'm
also a researcher at Newcastle
University's open lab in the UK the
interviews you're about to hear are part
of a series that along with the web
platform and connected classes seek to
create a space for critical engagement
with visual storytelling the
relationship between the photographer
the subject and the audience the three
stakeholders in every photograph a
central to the talking pictures
interviews but there are occasions when
those stakeholders might not be three
different people in the case of the
self-portrait the photographer and the
subject to the same person in the case
of the selfie that isn't shared or
published the photographer the subject
and the audience are one and the same
the theme for this session is
interpretation and the people who have
agreed to help us think about that are
the Scottish photographer Graham a
can-do and the u.s. journalist Susan
Stellan for reasons that will become
clear
Graham chose not to share his
self-portraits for over ten years
and many of the images from this series
and from this time in his life he's
still not chosen to publish both him and
Susan reflect on the ethical
implications of representing other
people the duty of care for the
vulnerable and they consider how the
effect and impact of an image might be
felt long after it was made and long
after the subject may have moved on with
their life I first met Graham in New
York in 1998 he helped me find a place
to live and help me find places to work
he was intense he was brash with his
thick Scottish accent that he refused to
let go of and he was funny he was
generous he was very caring of his
friends and he was successful as well he
was shooting news shooting huge jobs he
was travelling all over the world it was
someone who was constantly in motion
both figuratively and literally he was
also a compulsive collector both of the
ephemeral and an images everything had a
story attached to it and everything was
super tasteful as well to this day the
photographs of that period of my life
that hang in my home were made by Graham
we moved away from New York at the end
of 2001 and towards the end it had
become harder and harder to keep up with
him by 2005 it was impossible and it
remains a regret that we lost
back in the UK news of Graham now was
coming second and third-hand I learned
that he he'd got divorced I'd learned
that he wasn't working anymore
I learned that there'd been a newspaper
report of an explosion at his house that
he'd been arrested and that finally he
was in prison as you listen to this
interview you'll hear from Graham the
photographer Graham the subject and
Graham the publisher you'll hear how
even is Louis Debbie was still
considering the ethical implications of
making other people's images and how he
and Susan chose to share the work taking
into consideration how the contexts
would affect how the various audiences
would interpret it and be affected and
so it's fitting that susan has the last
word not only on this story but also on
this interview itself there are also
links to related bodies of work but
along with this material should inform a
critical discourse about vulnerability
responsibilities and how we choose to
represent issues and so frame the
conversations around them Graeme my
name's Graham maganda and speaking to
you guys from Brooklyn New York and my
living room and you might hear a few
Kerrigan bikers I'm pretty close to the
expressway I grew up in Scotland between
Edinburgh and Glasgow and you know I
spent a lot of my youth being into music
and specifically punk music in the late
seventies and through the 80s and I went
to art school in Edinburgh where I
actually studied painting and then
London I went to the Royal College which
was quite a jump for me because I hadn't
studied photography at all I'd study
pinning but I'd always taken photographs
and somehow I managed again to the Royal
College which was still pretty amazing
in Malaga and if it was very prestigious
at the time and then after two years at
the Royal College where I met my
then-girlfriend and had my son Liam
there I moved to New York to follow a
career in photography
when I first moved to New York I wasn't
sure what I was going to do in
photography I knew I wanted to work
within the field of photography I fallen
in love with it and was pretty
passionate about it but but five years I
spent working in galleries but because I
was always taking pictures eventually
moved on and working commercially as a
photographer before I knew I was
photographing for a lot of magazines
working on commercial ad campaigns
getting flown all over the world to do
annual reports and it's photographing
gary oldman I photographed Michael
Jackson I got sent a film set so I was
photographing you know for Nike and ESPN
so the trajectory at that point was
really really quick for me it wasn't am
I really in business for myself was
walking at that level as a commercial
photographer people would do stuff for a
year and so it was very fun I mean I was
always really surprised with people
through money and then give you money to
buy your breakfast in your lunch and a
cup of coffee and someone help you and I
taxi and all that stuff but that world
which really surprises me very very
surprising to me even I thought that I
was it was too much money sometimes and
I was getting paid it but of course not
all photography is really well kid you
know I mean journalism and editorial I
think is you can make a livin that it's
a good living but yet you're not getting
paid what you're getting paid for
shooting advertising campaigns and
that's where the real money comes in it
was interested be you know in a position
where people would call you up and say
hey you're available next week would
like to send you a la Randy Newman or
done an article on them but I've often
found that as the people that you get
sent that they have an interest and
story about them that are known that
celebrity banned words that are more
inclined could give you more time and
more implanted reveals things about the
cell even if you don't agree where I've
photographed some people that
politically I might know he was a you
know some of their stances I'm just like
wow but they also dress never done that
reveal something me about how other
people love that light those jobs are
more fulfilling for me you know I
enjoyed that so a you know meeting these
people have known the public eye
might be done some that slightly
interesting in Psalms picked up on it
and saw some magazines did a feature on
it I started working as a photographer
because I was someone who was always
taking pictures to portraits of friends
that have landscapes I did a photograph
livin that was going on around me you
know because I really loved photography
I still take pictures now I've always
taken pictures I mean I just sometimes I
think it's are almost like an affliction
I encourage all my students to keep
sketchbooks and not boots you know I
don't like them you take it out and
write notes on the phones I like them to
be carrying sketchbooks you know I tell
them and I send them on the first day in
class at the end of the semester
go to the store it's your fun the corner
spend five bucks buy a sketchbook and
just write your ideas and then scribble
ideas and if you find a piece of paper
or a picture on the street or a Polaroid
or whatever as stick it in there when
you look back through it will be much
more meaningful than a note on your
iPhone that you can delete accidentally
and doesn't have any real as their take
value after all thereby I'd like to get
my students to do a lot you know people
especially know people are very
interested in seeing what your vision is
and what you can bring to the table as
opposed to what you've brought to the
table for other people so I've had
several years of working as a really
successful commercial photographer
working editorially working for
advertising agencies flying are in the
world being lucky enough to meet
celebrities and you know such a dream
world of a photographer to be perfectly
honest with you but during that period
that started drinking too much I started
dabbling with drugs and it just took me
off at a tangent that I never ever
really expected in my life you know I
slowly but surely and Betty insidiously
the drugs kicked in and I became a very
very bad heroin and crack cocaine addict
I first met grandma can do in 2002 when
we were both part of the same summer
house out in Montauk as the end of Long
Island near New York at the time he was
working as a commercial photographer
her there were a lot of us who kind of
came and went to that house over the
course of the summer and I really just
knew him as someone who partied a bit
and drink I would say more than the
average person at the time he had a
girlfriend and we sort of lost touch
over that after that summer then I
reached out to him in 2005 when I needed
an author photo taken for a travel book
I'd written and went over to get my
picture taken at that point Graham
wasn't in that relationship anymore I
wasn't in a relationship and by the end
of that very long photoshoot in that
afternoon
the next day he asked me out on a date
I was living on the Upper West Side he
was living in Brooklyn and New York we
joked that that's sort of a
long-distance relationship you know we
really only saw each other on weekend so
it took a while for me to realize that
there was something a little bit off
about him we tend to see and experience
addiction as viewers at the extreme end
of the spectrum you know we don't really
have a popular conception of the
functional addict so for me the idea
that Graham could be functional as a
photographer and a guy that I would be
interested in dating at first people
just would ask well how could you not
have known it wasn't obvious to me and
you know we have pictures from a trip we
took to Hawaii and my mom when she saw
this photo she said oh he looked so
wholesome unbeknownst to me or really
anyone else he was using heroin at the
time I was still working for many years
during our times Arthur I'm still
working I'm making money I'm not that
bad you know this it just appears I'm
going through but you know as you get
more and more in it drugs your awareness
if where you are and what's going on
with you feathers away and but the time
I so realized and tried to dance number
I was really deepen I eventually found
out that Graham was using drugs when I
found him sitting on the couch in his
house at the crack pipe for a variety of
reasons I didn't end up breaking up with
him right then so I sort of stuck around
for a while you know and then until it
became apparent that he really just
wasn't getting the help and I thought me
being continuing a relationship was
actually hurting things more than was
helping and
think I had this feeling that you know
we all have that sort of tough love if I
just walk away you know that's going to
motivate him to quit I've always taken
pictures and even in the depths of my
addiction where I didn't work
commercially for years I was my whole
life was unraveling and isolating myself
from everyone that I knew and I was on a
very very slippery dark downhill path I
was still taking pictures but it wasn't
only the pictures that I was taken that
were so from that period I collected all
the being a compulsive collector of
things in my whole life and so I was
intrigued by the design of the heroin
baggies that I was buying around New
York City I didn't see it as collect at
a time I just kept them because I was
intrigued by them I love the designs I
love the quirky little pictures with
guns and cartoon characters and you know
statements on them that were just
totally over the top sometimes so I'd be
sticking them in books at little boxes
and stuff like that and also just other
things that were going on around me you
know I was writing in scrapbooks you
know I was keeping letters I was keeping
I got arrested a number a time I kept
the arrest warrants I kept all that
stuff court appearances we have paper
stuck them in boxes I was surprised when
I came through all that stuff and got
myself clean and a couple of different
friends of mine had stuck stuff in
storage or kept things in their houses
for me and I started pulling that stuff
together I started finding other stuff
again I started finding the heroin
baggies and the nut boots and the
Polaroids and the undeveloped rolls a 35
mil film and 120 film and and then I
started finding all these cards hundreds
and hundreds of pictures I had taken
during those years over maybe six or
seven years and no really not knowing I
was doing it and sometimes looking on
sometimes now looking on and sometimes
losing the cards and sometimes having
the cameras stolen by other junkies I
didn't feel I had the right to show the
pictures of the other people that I'd
photographed because the concent where
we were and it's a very very difficult
thing you'll see and do a lot of things
in an addict and see everyone's okay
then
the reality of day when you're clean you
just go my god I would never do or say
that so I've decided to make it all
about me another point in the code of
ethics is give special consideration to
vulnerable subjects and that's something
that graham has addressed and explaining
why he decided not to photograph other
addicts is this issue of consent
you know we recognize now that someone
who is addicted to drugs and has a
serious problem you know they have
difficulties with decision-making and
making rational choices so to say that
this person can consent to having their
picture taken and then published I think
is a bit problematic because you know we
recognize that you know they aren't
really making decisions that are
informed by rational choices and I think
that is something that we really need to
think about because that person might
get clean and then later regret that
their images out in the world you know
showing them at their worst moment and
they can't take it back I had started
taking photographs of the people are run
me in their environment and sometimes
I've ended up in the pictures and then
it just felt more pertinent for me to
photograph myself because I was living
that life and I shouldn't really be
pointing the camera at other people I
felt I should be pointed out myself
so fast forward a few years and I had
lost touch with him at that point he had
really gone downhill we kept in touch
occasionally via email but then he sort
of just disappeared off the radar and I
started reaching out to a couple other
people who had known him just sort of
under the assumption that maybe he'd
overdose because his phone had been
turned off the website you know he used
to promote his photography was offline I
mean I spent close to a decade in my
life juggling too much drinking dabbling
with drugs tonin a serious addiction and
everyone that went along with that and I
kept telling myself that I could get
clean on my own and I kept thinking over
some I could do just to willpower and
strands and it's just like I just need
to buckle down and dare but you know I
was totally incapable that strangely
enough the most devastating thing for me
at that
was a finally been arrested and
sentenced to six months in Rikers Island
which is a prison on an island on the
outskirts of New York City and I think
it's one of the biggest penal colonies
in the world which totally blew me away
because it was somewhere I never ever
thought I would end up and so I call
turkeys in a cell and Rikers Island
where it was a really really painful
thing you know the physicality of it and
then once you get that system a little
but the readjusting in your body to be
in clean and then psychologically the
you know realization of where the last
several years of your life have been a
really crushing you know I mean it's a
really really tough time for me but I
also gave me that moment a Clara is the
collet where I so it could look back and
say wow I just put myself through this
and my friends so that's my family
through this and thinking the collateral
damage to my mom and my dad and my
friends and my son and over him was
really big by the time I tracked him
down he was actually due to be released
from Rikers and rather than getting
released he ended up in Homeland
Security custody and was very quickly
moved to detention centers in first in
downtown Manhattan and then in New
Jersey and then Pennsylvania so I
managed to get someone at the prison
where he was being held in Pennsylvania
to give him my phone number and that's
when we reconnected I was in a County
Jail in Pennsylvania that had an
immigration wing and I found out they
had a 24/7 cognitive behavioral therapy
program in there for four months and
that's that's how I got clean
essentially was in a prison
rehabilitation program and it set the
groundwork for me to when I got to build
on that and I've been clean ever since
which is seven years on like that we
talked on the phone we exchanged these
really intense letters and you know by
the time his final hearing was coming up
it was as lawyer who actually asked if I
would be okay with Graham coming to stay
with me for a while if he got released
so all of a sudden he was on a bus
getting out at
the Port Authority Terminal near Times
Square in New York and that was the
first time we saw each other when we
were not separated by Plexiglas that was
the first time I seen him in almost two
years so he came to stay with me and
he's still here could never get rid of
him we actually just got married in May
of 2017 but when he was released
maybe not nine months clean but also
having spent nine months incarcerated so
he wasn't gram the photographer I think
he didn't know who he was and that was
the process of rebuilding you know not
just from that time away from everything
but also almost a decade of addiction so
it was a long process I mean he at first
he didn't have any interest in picking
up a camera he would go to a grocery
store and just stand in the aisles kind
of mystified by the amount of choice
that you had because all that's taken
away when you're incarcerated you know
he didn't have any interest in having a
phone he didn't have any interest in a
computer you know it took a long time
for Graham to you know feel pleasure
again from the things that I feel
pleasure from you know whether it's a
great meal or sex or running or
photography you know and that's because
your brain changes from addiction you
know particularly with dopamine's and
you know I don't think people get
prepared for how long that's going to
take
so now that I'm being clean for a bit
and I've started pulling together my
life and have rediscovered all this a
ephemera and stuff the photographs the
baggies the notebooks the Polaroids all
that sort of stuff from the use of
addiction I'd spent a lot of time
looking through them and it was somewhat
upsetting for me and I say looking at
these because even though I was clean
none I was happy I was clean and I was
near 100% comfortable talking to people
about what I've been through because I
was still in that place that said as an
addict your shame-based because it's not
like some that you boast about as being
a heroine addict or a crack addict or
some that you're pretty shamed of you
know so as a difficult thing to reveal
if people and some people alive people
knew about it some people didn't and I
would bump into people who would say oh
where have you been the last few year
have the healthy fairy jeez what was
being good on and the last thing you
want to say is oh hey it's good to see
you I've been a heroin addict I was
locked up in prison the first time I saw
them I mean it was just gut-wrenching
and it was it was so devastating but
also at the same time compelling because
it showed me what Graham had been up to
in these rooms and stairwells and places
that I'd never seen and I actually wrote
about it in a journal at the time where
I kind of described that attraction and
this voyeurism to wanting to know about
this part of his life he'd kept hidden
but then also how sad it was because
what Graham chose to show was so much
loneliness and in all the photos you
know by and large he's by himself and
just what his life had been reduced to
it took a lot of time looking at him
because some of the pictures were really
really really disturbing and some of the
really disturbing ones I have me put out
there because it's too rough on my
family and my wife and myself even
people who see certain images are just
too tough you know they they show me in
a light I just don't want to share when
he did start showing them to people
there were really a range of reactions
and what
friend of ours just you know ran crying
from the room when she first saw them it
was hard looking at it was hard walking
at who the audience would be why would I
want to show who would this resonate
with and what would be their takeaway it
was like I took these pictures of myself
and this is what I went through and I
want you to understand people end up in
this situation and what they goes
through and that they can recover as
well really important to me the you know
the takeaway for this is that you can go
through this stuff and you can recover
I think that's missing PA addiction for
SES and stuff like that is people a
perfect laugh it photographs the addicts
the junkies the torn down buildings or
the desolate isolated places and they're
always a lot of the times in victims and
they always never seem to recover and
never seems to be an end story about
really look at these addicts so I want
you to show look at this addict coming
from me as the recovered addict when
Graham first started talking about or
proposing that he might show these
images to some photo editors or think
about publishing them or exhibiting them
my first reaction was that that was a
really scary thought you know not
negative that he shouldn't do it but
just concern about how these images
would be interpreted so one of the
things that I suggested is that if he
was going to publish these images that
he include text accompanying the images
that he tell his story so that he could
to some degree shape how people reacted
to them my response from magazines was
immediate I sent emails to a couple of
picture editors was a couple in baby
pictures and was then like half an hour
which is unknown for picture writers
they were back at me saying oh we love
these can you bring them in can you show
us more were really interesting
publishing them we eventually decided to
publish them was text by Susan which was
an interview basically and in New York
magazine and it got so much feedback but
because we mulled over it for so long it
was a really well-done piece and it
really resonated I was really happy with
it and the feedback from the people that
saw it their audience was
amazing so after the article it first
appeared in New York Magazine in print
and obviously there was an accompanying
piece online that did have the
photography and the text and some audio
we literally sat looking at the computer
waiting for the comments to start
scrolling in there was a person who
thought that Graham had faked to this
whole thing in order to get published
and you know potentially get an exhibit
and that really sparked this thread
about whether or not someone who was a
heroin addict really would have the
capacity to set a self timer and take
pictures of himself and I think that
gets back to this idea that we don't
really understand or believe in the
concept of someone who can be somewhat
functional or in some cases very
functional while using drugs but there
are myriad stories of people who you
know have held down careers as doctors
surgeons lawyers actors professors and
then it comes out that you know they had
a serious addiction but yet I think
sometimes because we don't see that
depicted and visual imagery we just we
can't wrap our heads around it so in a
lot of the Guardian comments there was
just the skepticism was he really a
heroin addict was he really using from
there it got picked up by al-jazeera The
Huffington Post and that led me to the
Scottish National Portrait Gallery where
the curator there approached me and said
listen I've never seen anything like
this before can you bring these to me
and let me see these pictures these are
amazing you know so I went across and
met with her and I took maybe I made a
whole bunch of eight by ten prints maybe
the eighth year mainly we looked through
them
I left them was her I came back three
months later we were all that done it
like 50 came back three months later we
were all done like 25 images that were
really powerful and succinct and we
submitted them as a board to the
Scottish National Portrait Gallery to
see if we could get an acquisition to my
surprise I got it woke up one morning
checked my email and there was an email
from an enlightened who's a curator said
you'll never believe it the dis idea to
acquire all 25 images for the national
collection which was
mind-boggling image they think back
they've taken these pictures these dark
places these isolated painful times that
you know the hope all through the boards
and committees in the National Portrait
Gallery which is a very traditional body
of people found this body of works so
compelling and powerful that they were
the quiet of the national collection
which is a real really great for me it
was really a catalyst to these
conversations that I think people were
really anxious and interested in having
so the series of images became sort of a
gateway to these conversations about not
just addiction but how do you get clean
you know what is that like what is that
process what did you do what helped you
AIESEC Graham's route to recovery is you
know something that is going to work for
everybody but I think the more we talk
about it the more we can kind of learn
about what works in different
circumstances one of the reasons that
we're we mostly see images of addiction
and addiction sort of at the far end of
the spectrum is just the shame and the
stigma that surrounds you know substance
use disorder the imagery is always about
the person who's really lost everything
they're really down and out that's
something that's also missing
you know from media and kind of popular
representations of addiction is that
recovery piece of it because you know
it's maybe not as interesting visually
Graham keeps asking you know how do you
depict recovery you know what do you
show about that you know where with
addiction I think there is that
voyeurism factor it's something that you
know people you know largely haven't
seen although I would argue that maybe
at this point we have seen a lot of
images of needles going into veins or
people passed out or you know crack
pipes or drugs kind of close up and I
think where we're at now is kind of
trying to wrap our heads around what is
that project or story that you can tell
about how people get clean and sober
some people recover without doing you
know a rehab or without going to AAA
other people really rely on those peer
supports so I think you know finding a
way to capture those
stories and capture that process is
something that we're both really
interested in right now I think it's the
most important thing I've I've really
done is put this body work out there and
engage with people and you know as
someone who's been the addict and the
recover person and reviewing that part
in my life and trying to take away some
of that shame and trying to take away
some of that negative it is a Sorrows
addiction and giving people that option
that you know what you can go that duck
and that deep and end up the places I've
been and still cool yourself at that and
find recovery and built rebuild your
life again and it's now easy there was
times where it were really really really
tough but you know what being clean is
it million times better than being a
headache that's for sure you know so you
know I mean it's been a crazy journey
and a long journey and a tough journey
for some of the friends I've seen me go
through that yourself included but at
least I came away from it with something
that can help change other people's
minds and bring light to what people
mean bill so and that's been really
really important for me all right you
got it
is it yes you say nothing that's about
so now that you've heard my story and
grand story and listened to you know
these interviews I kind of challenge you
to think about what we've talked about
and how much of the focus has been on
addiction and the process of you know
going from being a successful
photographer to someone who was had lost
everything and ended up in a prison cell
versus the time spent on you know
talking about in addressing grams
recovery and the treatment he got and
you know how that worked because I think
we all have to step back and see how
we're representing this issue and sort
of challenge ourselves to think about it
in different ways and
so challenge some of the stereotypes we
have about what does addiction look like
you know is it just the photographs that
we see of people like Graham who are
slumped over with a needle in their arm
and when we talk about it why are we
drawn to that imagery more than two
images of people sitting in circles or
interviews of people talking about you
know what they had to overcome the peer
support they got you know and some that
is in some sense it's harder to
photograph it's harder to get access but
that's part of the process that we need
to be seeing and talking about and
thinking about because that's really key
to figuring out what works to help
people who are struggling with addiction